marketing for the now the marketing for
the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hi everyone i'm tim lindley managing
director of vaynermedia asia pacific and
welcome to our first
ever apac edition of vayner x present
marketing for the now
one hour six guests one question for
ceos founders and cmos who are leading
the way in their respective industries
today's focus how do you accelerate
transformation
hashtag marketing for the now gary you
ready
i am always ready tim there we go let's
go
okay to kick off the show we welcome
rupendasai
global cmo at the dole sunshine company
a company that believes everyone should
have equal access to health and
nutrition
rupen's team recently jumped into the
nft space creating a collection with
acclaimed artist david detuna
to increase awareness of food insecurity
and malnutrition worldwide
raising funds towards alleviating hunger
today
rupen welcome to the show thank you
thank you tim and thank you gary for
having me
again it's great to see you
uh this time an addition that is
more specific to the region so repent uh
let's just get right into it because
it's only 10 minutes as you know
you know how you know how do you
through your lustrous career think about
accelerating transformation like
for a lot of people that are on this
watching on youtube you know
linkedin facebook i'm seeing the
comments come in they are in smaller
businesses entrepreneurial stuff
so it's always interesting to for them
to
listen in on people driving bigger
organizations because they don't deal
with the politics
or the lack of speed your the companies
you're involved in
have the resources are bigger those are
advantages but
it's hard to drive transformation
because it's a big
ship you know and so
i'd love to get a sense for the fellow
c-suite fortune 5000 individuals that
are watching
um where do you kind of uh
where do you kind of see that play
so gary transformation starts with
accepting
i don't know what i don't know and what
that
what that gives rise is a lot of fear a
lot of
uncertainty a lot of a lot of
blank blankness okay
and most large organizations
are tremendously focused on a constant
improvement of the current systems
the current management the current
status quo
and there is therefore a big imagination
gap which when combined with fear
which when combined with having the
humility to
accept that i don't know what i don't
know can be terrific terrifying
can be terrifying and and and you know
it reminds
it reminds me of that famous uh
bernard shaw george bonnet shaw's quote
which was
uh some people see things as they are
and ask why
and others dream that never were and ask
why not and
and very few and very few organizations
are able to
ask why not and then jump into it
knowing that
failure is almost certain
do you believe that that's because most
organizations
are driven by people who
have less entrepreneurial spirit are
more comfortable drawing within the
lines
are more risk adverse because they're
rewarded to be risk adverse
because that's just the truth of it yeah
i mean most
see as an organization grows larger your
first
need is to create systems to control
to create order to issue handbooks to
give
people i don't know do it frameworks who
decides who owns
and what what we don't realize is what
we are killing
uh is creativity what we are creating is
an imagination gap
and and therefore companies as they grow
larger are destined to be
less creative unless there is a
conscious
effort to to create a space for people
to stumble
i mean if you look at most of the large
companies they never
started off gary uh where
where they are today i mean 3m it was a
mining company
you know what's that 30 billion plus
plus
most companies when they get to that
level of scale
would make the founders of those
companies throw up all over
uh i'm starting to throw up all over
myself on vaynermedia i'm currently
running it
it's my company and even at 1500 people
i'm like how many [ __ ] meetings do
people have to have
where there's 12 people in the meeting
for an hour
when it's really a four-person meeting
for 30 minutes
but everyone's got to be part of the
meeting because they feel
left i mean i don't even like my own
company let alone
what the company will look like in 35
years when it has
25 000 people no there's a huge there's
a huge difference like i call it the
rocking horse phenomena at dole
right a lot of people within a system
outside
tend to sit in a rocking horse go whoa
whoa whoa look mama look
to realize that they're still in the
same place
you differentiate between motion and
progress
and a lot of organizations sometimes
tend to confuse the two
and and and continue to stay in the
rocking horse
i mean can you can you imagine being
going back to that 3m phenomena being in
mining
discovering sandpaper discovering it
doesn't work
to suddenly selling adhesives and paper
and uh
and a sticker that didn't stick i mean
and the list is endless so sometimes i
think
we don't give enough merit to stumbling
from i mean that's that's why little
companies
beat big companies like there's a reason
why
david beats goliath because
goliath has lost its way
i mean you want to hear something
incredible repent like when i started
vaynermedia
i knew so little about adland i thought
that vaynermedia was going to get the
this is i made this up which is you know
my first mistake i thought big companies
had 20
of their money allocated for innovation
yeah i thought if you run pepsi dole
starbucks that you have a budget and 80
is to run the business day to day
quarter to quarter all the [ __ ] that i
anticipated
and 20 was to build it for the future
and i was going to come in
and crush that literally it was a cold
shower with
the first couple months i'm like wait a
minute a hundred percent of the money
is played over here and oh by the way
it's spent on [ __ ] that was relevant 10
years ago
so i thought i was going to be over here
with 20
and meanwhile all the money's over here
and it
literally in 2009 believed print was
more valuable than social
there's still organizations that kind of
believe that
but but gary most leaders grew up
perfecting a formula
and the fear of trying the unknown and
failing and failing miserably
particularly at day and time when most
organizations
don't no matter what they say about
let's fail forward
let's embrace transformation those are
off sites
those are off sites filled with [ __ ]
for optics
so unless unless unless we create and it
comes right from the top it comes from
the board
unless there is a genuine
embrace of the fail
not no let's be five blind people trying
to define an
elephant call what you may call it uh
it is it is basically a bit of speak and
a nice ceo conference a bit of offside
but it's never genuine transformation
and and
and there's another piece of
transformation i want to talk about
because a lot of us talk
to people like a lot of us about the
issues we're having of
why is my wi-fi not good enough but you
know
70 of the world still probably needs to
deal with hunger
sanitation of course it's all contextual
something you're complaining about is a
privilege
somewhere else and you know i think we
have to be empathetic to that
um and the and and deploy that
perspective but it's just not
the way and it's definitely not the way
of big companies no and if we're talking
transformation in the real world
uh not not i mean i i saw the work
winning it can and i
admired some of it and i thought
wouldn't that amazing we've sold the
refugee problem
everybody can now register on a offline
phone great well done and then you go
yes
but that bubble lasted a week maybe two
weeks maybe five weeks i don't know
that i'm not commenting on that piece of
work but i'm commenting on work like
that in general
we've got to find those solutions that
transform the world and make it a bit
more equitable
we can't have the haves talking to the
haves about the issue of the haves and
quality transformation
audacity i mean
but but it starts with the fact of even
thinking
judging work for awards that are used
for proxies to get business
like it goes it's your statement there
was meta
like sure but like the context of even
judging award shows for work that nobody
really even sees
so that we can speak in an eco these
normal people on the stream right now
have no idea what the [ __ ] we're talking
about when it comes to tv commercials
everyone's wondering about how am i
going to pay rent
what am i going to do or let's not even
go altruistic let's go marketing
let's just do marketing let's not even
go big let's go small
marketing we sit in rooms judging work
shaking each other's hands for big
commercials
tv commercials that none of these people
right here even know what the [ __ ] we're
talking about
anyway go please last words
we're fooling ourselves we're fooling
ourselves
uh and we're doing the worst damage we
could to our business by doing that
i couldn't agree more that is my that is
my passion every day knowing that
we're in the industry but not of it yes
cheers yeah take care bye
oh rupen thank you so much we'll just
start the show um
yeah tim that was some we just got right
into the [ __ ] right
this is what we get into here tim this
is like you're part of a different org
now this is not
political correct hour brought to you by
vader x like let's get into real talks
we have a lot of people in the chat
who don't know the marketing advertising
world
and and really associate with
these conversations so let's keep it
moving absolutely
yeah so look next up um another heavy
hitter
welcome uh yuan tan ceo of pepsico aipac
uh un leaves the company's food and
beverage business across asia pacific
one of the most dynamic regions in the
world especially for this business uh
previously he was president and ceo of
walmart china
and led the business through a massive
transformation to become an industry
pioneer
not only in omnichannel innovation um
but also in retail digitization
um and he started his career as a police
officer here in singapore
so uh here we go welcome you in over to
you
thank you thanks for having me you and
what's uh
what's uh what's more gangster being a
police officer
or navigating the corporate marketing
world
i can tell you both are equally
gangsters
you know the the interesting thing about
being a police officer when you're
really young
is it teaches you a lot about empathy
and those skills can go a long way and
that's what's uh you know
really also quite important in the
corporate world i agree
and for everybody who's watching a
little context of what's going on with
pep you know again global audience
watching but you know
my intuition is predominantly north
america with the sprinkling of
europe and apac and south america what's
what's the state of the union of the
of the brand in in that region
is there any uniqueness for blue can or
any of the regional brands
just one minute on that and then we'll
get into how you think about
accelerating transformation
sure absolutely gary so you know as many
of your audience
would know we are a global company with
many well-loved brands
23 billion dollar brands i think
counting more than 40 250 million dollar
brands
globally so all those brands that you
know from you know north america or
europe whether it's pepsi mountain dew
bubbly gatorade
lace doritos they're all here in apec
but we also have some really unique
propositions here for instance our
australia business has a red rock daily
premium line of
snacks crackers we've expanded into nuts
and seeds as well
uh recently we've also taken the quaker
brand uh that you might know in our
cereal
into things like uh granola we launched
a new product
uh coffee granola and yogurt bite
granola so it's
really exciting innovation happening in
this space and last year we also
acquired an online
direct to consumer company that's the
largest in china
of its kind uh selling all kinds of
snacks from nuts and seeds to dried
fruits to meat snacks so
we are diversifying the portfolio a lot
we're innovating to meet the needs of
the local consumers
and it's a really exciting time to be
part of pepsico and also to be part of
apac
i'm really glad that you decided to do a
show here because you know it's a
really dynamic region of the world uh
and earlier we talked about
um rupen was talking about the burning
platform right yes
there's three things that are common
about apec consumers and markets i think
would be one the pace of change
you think about fmcg has been fast but
here at apec it's about 10
times the speed consumers here embrace
new ideas really quickly
and they often think digital and mobile
first
and there's just so much optimism about
growth potential those three things
really force you to accelerate
transformation because whether you're a
big company like pepsico or a small
company trying to make a mark in the
world
you have to move quickly and you have to
transform if you are
stuck in an industry that is seeing a
lot of impact from
various forces what do you think um
what do you think from your perspective
walmart included with retail being that
close
transformation do you believe big
companies
spend enough time actually understanding
the consumer
or do you think they spend too much time
within the confines
of what their financial objective is
that's a great question i would say you
know
uh the common and dodgers if you don't
pay for today you can't
have it tomorrow right so every company
that's listed
has to answer to investors has to make
sure that we deal with the returns
but i think that's the job of leadership
which is to
make sure that you secure tomorrow but
you also build a new future
for uh you know 25 30 years out
and that's what we're doing at pepsico
it's not easy
there are short-term pressures you know
this year you see a lot of impact on
commodity costs for instance
i'm excited about the project we're
taking at pepsico you know and
if you think about how to run this sort
of business
i really think about the organization as
comprising different types of businesses
so you've got
you know startups within the company
that are trying to manage and
set up from zero to one the kind of
talent that you want in these
roles um may not be the kinds that are
great
moving your business from 95 to a
hundred i'm sorry to interrupt you but i
think you're making a huge point i want
to make sure everybody gets in willie
have a couple minutes
how much is casting
a huge variable in the game that you
play to actually
create short-term success and viability
and create transformation like i think
you're touching on the most important
like
it's actually scary in my opinion how
big of a deal casting is
you were just speaking to it you agree
yeah it's critically important because
the way big corporations have thought
about talent in the past is
you're going to join this company and
you're going to stay for you know 20
years and make a career out of it
i think in future if we want to run new
businesses we want to get entrepreneurs
to come in and become entrepreneurs
then when you think about careers as
people who come in and do missions for
three to five years they have a
starting line and a finish line and what
what defines success
and after that we should be happy for
them to move on to other things
because they're excited by the new and
not necessarily about you know taking
something from
one to ten or ten to a hundred when you
say new do you think at the scale that
you play at
new within your world like let's send
them to europe to run
gatorade or you mean new like screw it
people are going to be in and out of our
global four walls every three to five
years
i mean new as in let's reserve a chunk
of money where we can go and try really
crazy stuff that i think
uh it's not under maybe even one of our
brands
let's go innovate against an area or you
know invest in some startups that can
collaborate with us
to innovate in a space that we've never
innovated before but that's still called
a pepsico's
uh consumer agenda which is to drive
more smiles
and through sips and bites for consumers
around the world
what's been the most interesting
transformation you've actually well
you've got two more minutes
you've been a part of like it what's in
your entire career whether you're a
young buck
or yesterday um what's like
you saw it in your real own eyes and you
couldn't
even really believe it when you and the
team were done with it
yeah you know the the most fascinating
transformation taking place
right now is actually uh e-commerce
in china right okay and if you think
about how the industry has evolved it's
really
into its third phase now in the first
phase it was you know the amazons of the
world alibaba
is delivering from warehouses uh that
business is struggling right now
you now have store-based fulfillment you
know the e-convenience folks like
instacart etc
and that's really booming but in china
you now have a third phase of e-commerce
which is
really consumer-centric content-based
e-commerce so when
tik-tok decides they want to sell to
consumers too it's a very different way
of marketing you need
companies to think about the the
consumer
in a very centric way rather than the
channels and the platforms
and that's a big change i can't say that
any companies have mastered it but if
you look at what
you know mormont's doing in the us
they're also taking a lot of learnings
from what's happening in china to an
apec
uh to the rest of the world and i think
that's paying dividends as well
yeah i think that's right i think that's
where global companies have a huge
advantage because there's so many things
uniquely aipac and china driven
that haven't hit other places yet it's
human driven
and it's going to work everywhere else
yeah absolutely i mean i'll give you
another example from
my old uh employees at mcdonald's right
delivery is responsible for a huge part
of the
stock price over the last 10 years and
but 10 years ago the delivery business
in this part of the world and in markets
like singapore korea taiwan was really
30
of total sales so it's uh you know there
are lots of trends that you can see
happening here because of how um
how the consumers really embrace new
ideas and it will start to hit the rest
of the world
my friend thank you so much for being on
the show it's a real pleasure and honor
thanks gary you're in thank you i was on
asia for
e-common d2c innovation it's truth
um amazing okay let's keep going our
next guest is lynette pang
i'm assistant chief executive of the
marketing group of singapore tourism
board
tourism tough uh tough 18 months in
tourism
then that's responsible for building
singapore as a destination brand
globally
she leads both consumer and business
marketing across all comms channels
more than 20 key markets she's a very
very impressive career
uh lynn has worked in entertainment
sports health education
including stints with formula 1 yahoo
and warner brothers
and now the brand singapore uh welcome
lynette
hey hi tim hi gary a very good evening
and thanks for
casting the spotlight on apec my
pleasure and it's great to see you again
i really enjoyed some of our prior
combos why don't um like before we get
into transformation
i'm just genuinely curious as someone
who's responsible for tourism
you know one of you and i'm you know i'm
gonna make assumptions over the last 18
months you've had some conversations
with other people that are in charge of
it for other parts of the world you've
all been in the same basket
how difficult how difficult were these
18 months
and more importantly you know how are
you thinking about
you know really accelerating
you know transforming to be prepared
for the appetite or the different
behaviors
you know when i think about singapore
there's so much business travel
that people then take into leisure how
many of those become
zoom meetings like how are you prepping
because i think you're what's
really interesting is we're talking in
theory or history
with some of the guests here today i
think you're in the eye of the storm
of thinking about how to accelerate
transformation because you're gonna have
to deal with some sort of new reality
and it's gonna move on you quickly so
when i drop all of that
how do you synthesize that and what are
some of the things that come to mind
that's a really difficult and long
question gary
perhaps i can begin with two data points
in talking about the state of play in
terms of tourism in singapore
it's been very hard if you look at
if you cast it and you look at it in
terms of before and after
before covet we had four years of
blockbuster growth
um and and
and it was record-breaking growth and
post-covet
our visitor arrivals dropped by 85
percent
so it has been an existential
um problem right and and if you're
thinking about another piece of
statistic which which i was researching
on uh
to prep for this discussion uh mckinsey
global did a survey
in july 2020 on transformation among
c-suites
c-suites and senior managers and this
was
the statistic that really jumped out at
me the share of digitally
or digital enabled products in company
portfolios has accelerated by a shocking
seven years in apec
was 10 years and this was in july
last year so the rate of change
in asia and in singapore in the heart of
asia
has been fast and brutal and harsh
so one of the key things about what we
do at sinful tourism part is
it's really about um how can we lead the
industry and how can we help the
industry right
so the questions we've asked ourselves
has been we framed it in in three time
frames
in the short term how can we rapidly
quickly just give aid
to help businesses survive zero business
zero tolerance right
and then in the midterm we need to think
about very quickly
what are the tools in place that we can
help the industry
grow at scale we're talking about uh
back end transformation we're talking
about platforms
and that's the midterm question that's
tough right because that's about
learning and changing ways of doing and
of course that's the prep for
the mid to long term which you talked
about briefly which is about
you know when when markets open how can
singapore be distinctive
how can singapore create an amazing
experience
so that we we are a pool destination
so it's about helping them thrive um
and how we've been thinking about it
would be there are three things i can
talk
i can talk about today one would be
really about
the entire digital transformation but
transformation is not just digital
two really we're in the business of
experience creation
we're in the business of whether you
come to singapore for business for
leisure
i need to bring a little bit of pleasure
right and fun to your experience so it's
about
experience re-engineering and and the
third
bucket really is about we are talking
about transformation we need to ask
ourselves
yes we need scrappy we need to test fast
after that we need to think very quickly
about how to scale
and one of the ways at the organization
that we've been thinking about scaling
is through working with others
partnerships excuse me
yeah i'll jump in everybody look over
here a bird
no i'm just kidding um
keep going so
if you're thinking about digital
transformation
really there are a couple of things that
we're looking at
the question we asked ourselves was how
can we look at building systems
improving processes at scale to help the
industry transform
very luckily for us these were things
that we were thinking about and
some of them we've built but the
adoption rate perhaps was slow
sure with the business problem that was
real
adoption accelerated which was
which was good in the way but
unfortunate that we needed that problem
to
you believe for big organizations
that the almost the only time
first of all hold on is that like that
might be the coolest water
we've got lemon in there what else is in
what's going on in there
vitamin c and this this was actually
made by a social enterprise in singapore
i love that it's to help people with
autism and they make beautiful crafted
products gorgeous
so don't you believe large large
organizations
really unfortunately only act during
crisis
um i i don't
i think i don't think we can say across
the board
of course yeah of course but like you
know when you when you look at kind of
the last you know your career you've
been in some big organizations
we big organizations like to talk about
moving faster but really only crisis
gets them to really move at the speed of
accelerating transformation
of the ambition of let's say the
individuals on this call
right you know it seems that only when
that happens
like it was it blew my mind how many
cmos
only because of covid finally looked at
what was going on on tick tock
finally paid attention to the organic
reach on linkedin finally started to
debate if production costs were way too
crazy you know
because it's just the reality of of how
it is
you know gary i think one of the things
that's been um
a great change in the past perhaps five
to seven years has been
that the talk and and and about
building in you know okay it sounds like
a truism and sounds a bit trite but
i just want to touch on this a little
bit about building a disruption in your
company right
in building perhaps a ban of of
crazy people who think about you know
testing and learning and doing
things that perhaps might not fit into
the business objective for the time
being and i think
that has been built into a lot of major
big companies
in the west i've seen and definitely in
apec
and i think as the singapore tourism
what we have to do
given that we're the government with a
slightly different rule so we've had to
think about
how do we then um build this mentality
in big companies and at the same time
help
small companies change so a couple of
things that we've done is we've built
systems
easy systems one system that we built is
small companies you might not have
content about singapore
you might not have the latest
information of singapore
how can i help all these small companies
in singapore
and around the world talk about
singapore consistently
imaginatively so we built a back and
called the tourism
information hub through apis you can
have the latest contents
latest visuals latest information about
the attractions we have
and the rate of adoption was it was
difficult to get people to understand
what it was
it was challenging to get people to
adopt it with covered
adoption rates have saw likewise
the other backend that we've built is
really about
data we built a data center
which we've opened up just prior to
coffin
so that the industry are able to have
data
at scale and they're able to make very
data-led decisions about
um their customers so
your neighbors we see yes we need to
enable it's huge
it's exactly right i'm i'm was so
interested i'm sorry we've run out of
time it's such a pleasure to see you
uh and i hope you have a tremendous rest
of the summer thank you
thank you thanks so much lynette
challenging time for tourism for sure um
so fascinating to hear thank you
but you know now they're on the back end
right tim like now we're now it's time
to go on the offense
as somebody who loves to watch human
behavior i'm
dying to see what all happens
it's amazing like the inflection point
that's about to come but let me give you
an example
i am literally going to los angeles
tomorrow and taking the red eye home
i literally all of kovitz said i would
never take a red eye again
and i'm doing it tomorrow because
it's what humans do yeah you just go
back to what you used to do
yeah and it's gonna be a mix i mean i
took i had a meeting today tomorrow i
have a meeting friday that i probably
would have flown for
so it's gonna be a mix but like
what i have to do in la tomorrow is just
real human life
yeah sometimes you just need it but it's
a lot of talk about
how this maybe has killed the business
day trip and now you're just talking
about that
yeah people go into some definitive like
this or that it's always and
yeah will i take every trip that i used
to no
am i going literally [ __ ] tomorrow
and red eyeing back i'm literally awake
i have a 4 30 wake up
4 30 no at 4am wake up and i land
at 6am like it's crazy but it's just
real life anyway keep moving it really
is
awesome okay let's move on uh joining us
next we have simon khan
simon's the head of marketing for google
in asia pacific
so he currently oversees strategy
research brand management advertising
everything all google consumer products
all business solutions
16 countries in the region um he's
helped transform apac into one of
google's fastest growing regions
worldwide so this should be a great
discussion
let's jump in welcome simon thank you
tim
thank you gary good to see you how are
you pleasure it's i'm really well thank
you my friend thanks for being on
um simon when you when you think about
this and
and you've been executing because i'm a
fan from afar
what what are the ingredients what what
can we tell the young executives the
entrepreneurs and definitely the senior
executives
at the scale that you're playing at what
has been the secret
to getting something to actually
accelerate at the speed that i'm
noticing and you've got so many products
so many objectives
you know what uh what's been at the
forefront
well i think it you know goes down to
culture and casting and i know you were
talking earlier with one of the guests
that we're on casting and it is i think
it's incredibly valuable
if if you start with culture uh you you
need to set an environment where you're
rewarding risk
um you're you're making sure you're
listening to everybody in the
organization
um and in many ways you're reducing
friction right so you're pushing
accountability and responsibility
down as far as possible yes uh you're
helping people understand that we're
driving for opportunity
and it's not just about sort of keeping
the engine moving but finding the next
thing the next thing the next thing
um and then on the casting side real
quick on that i apologize you inspired
me
to follow up one of the things i think
about
all the time is eliminating fear
which leads to speed but i'm a crazy
character
have a young smaller company and i watch
my people who've been with me for 18
months who've been
given 37 data points of why they
shouldn't
still have trepidation because of the
culture
of societal business you know when i
hear you talk
thinking about my realities and kind of
the small the investments i've made and
watched companies like facebook and
twitter and uber like
i've i'm unfortunate of what i've been
able to see at this young age
uh it's fascinating how challenging
that is even when you and your heart
have
all those intents purely people still
parents they grew up with societal norms
a prior experience that they i mean
the bat and business yeah please i think
this is even
uh more accentuated in a place like
aipac where you go to societal norms
there's a lot of respect for
hierarchy there's a lot of respect for
your elders uh
and and so you have to push hard against
it right so it's it's a fear
i think that every every senior exec
from any big company has is that you're
going to get too slow
and and you're going to lose out on on
that opportunity so i think a lot of
this
is about backing up your people right so
you you give them accountability
and and when they make mistakes you sort
of
you know you celebrate they took that
chance and
and and you know you make sure that they
understand that
you're going to be with them through the
good times and the bad
when did that happen for you in reverse
in your career early on anecdotally an
actual
story maybe give a shout out to somebody
who did right by you
yeah so i one of my job before this was
with american express
and you know american express is old
established company
really well run but taking risks is is a
difficult thing
and at one point i was running the
centurion card business in the united
states
uh said black card business yep and we
were debating
uh sort of major changes in pricing and
in terms of the way the product was
going to be organized and
and put out to customers and uh al kelly
who's
is now the the ceo of um a visa but used
to be a senior executive at
amex really backed me up in a crucial
situation where i was taking a big risk
and was to it was going to have
something that was going to have a
material effect on on the company on the
product certainly
and and you know just just to see him do
that and
to back up somebody who was relatively
junior at that time was so
empowering right and so it's one of
those things that i've looked to
replicate
why do you think that happened well i
think you know i came to the table
with the the right data the right
information but fundamentally i think he
had trust in the person
right he had trust and as a leader he he
trusted that i was
i was prepared and i was doing the right
thing i love that
um what uh
what do you think needs to be
transformed
most in big companies as you have this
great
purview yeah i think there are a couple
things one
is you need to make sure you're thinking
beyond what is happening within your
company and not looking
at the market or looking at consumers or
your potential customers
within just the lens of your existing
product set
because you're going to miss the new
trends if you do that and and you need
to continue to think and be
expansive and understand like the trends
that for years have been coming out of
asia that are now hitting
the west but you know for a long time a
lot of companies in the west
just didn't understand it because it was
a whole different business model uh
so you know one thing is to be focused
there
i think the second thing is to just
again
get to this point of of having people in
the organization
that bring a variety of mindsets right
and this is where i get to casting right
you need some oddballs you need some
people who will actually create
friction and add some really interesting
perspectives to that conversation
it actually and also helps quite a bit
with diversity and inclusion right you
get some
a whole diversity of opinions and
backgrounds into the conversation
how have you noticed the oddballs
you know it's really funny for me
because i think it's you know
it's a very important combo because for
me
and my framework the oddballs are the
reverse
from my perspective right right the
people that play within the lines
those a students yeah those corp right
because i know where you're going and i
think it's a very important good point
what's been so interesting for me is i
only lived in entrepreneurship
and then i came over the last 13 years
at corporate and for me
still to this day the oddball the thing
that feels
off to me is the 98 of people i interact
with
yeah like to me it's charlie brown it's
like i i literally
know every meeting how it's going to go
because everyone's playing the same book
yeah how how you have to create a
culture
that allows entrepreneurs to be
comfortable at least a bit comfortable
within that environment
right so 100 right you if you if you
cycle through
sort of folks who um are the the grain
in the system
uh but they just constantly leave
because they're dissatisfied
how do you get the non-oddballs in that
scenario
to appreciate what the oddball's doing
because
i laugh at the non-oddballs
eye-rolling at the odd ball in a world
where
the non-oddballs don't realize they're
playing the mundane and they're the
commodity
yeah but they well yeah you said a
culture and you know
and we've talked about this for a while
at google this whole concept of 10x
thinking right so
and coming from my previous background a
10x thinking would get you fired
right but if you have if you have that
sort of sense of like
look we need to be audacious we need to
take on these big challenges
and this person has some crazy ideas but
there's something here
so let's let's figure this out and let's
let's constructively
um sort of attack those ideas and and
build up to something that's uh that
could be viable
i think that's one of the key things you
have to do but it starts from that
setting that culture
i'm a fan of that conversation simon
thank you so much and continued success
thank you good to see you thanks simon
amazing absolutely loving this um
when you're willing to talk real [ __ ]
with really strong people
you can have like the the comment
section i don't know if you're reading
it tim like
and again a lot of people watching are
entrepreneurial early in their careers
you know we've looked at data most the
c-suite watches
kind of in-feed later like these are
really interesting perspectives that
may not on surface seem to impact the
person who's got a
who's an entrepreneur or junior member
an organization but it really the
thematics matters so much
it really does and the focus i guess i
mean it's amazing to get time with with
these people like the schedules are
insane and just people would kill for
these moments so let's keep going i
think just this experience coming
through is incredible
um okay right amazing so next up next we
have jean jean madden
she's the cmo of next-gen foods and the
company behind tyndall
chicken made from plants jean's a bit of
a marketing maestro
i've known her for a while actually i've
seen her through this journey it's
really it's really been amazing
she brings consumer insight brand
storytelling together in her own way
she has a wealth of fmcg experience um
and numerous awards but she's now
bringing her flair to tyndall
um and and it really is taking the world
by storm so gene
welcome to the show love the t-shirt
awesome yeah i gotta gotta support the
swag right so how are you gary great to
be here
chatting about accelerated
transformation i think it's
pretty apt when you think about that we
started the company you know
10 months actually eight months ago
launched the global brand
expanded it internationally and then
today chatting with the legendary you
on marketing for the now so it seems to
be a pretty good time
you're very sweet thank you for that and
by the way the the
font on the brand is incredible um
i love it it's kind of that old school
cartoon font i love it
when you think about this obviously
having this great career you're still
extremely young in your journey
and then now being in this spot where
you are
where it is moving fast yeah this is
different than some of the kind of other
organizations what have you siphoned
in your first sniff in this role in this
organization
that you're like oh okay this is this is
what i've
heard it like what kind of maybe
whether it caught you off guard or not
let's frame it a different way
what was an observation early on of like
oh
i see why this is different anything
stand out
absolutely i think a a lot you know it
was a very big
i mean i came from a very kind of
traditional
background very large companies very
large organizations and then
you know dipped my feet into making
chicken made from plants which
you know it's kind of it's kind of
insane and decided to just kind of take
this
this they're really not really not
insane right gene like i'm sure this is
what like
your decision like like if i had to bet
the farm
on fungus based like like on all these
alternate like
it's so obvious to me it is so obvious
and
i mean it's a it's a huge huge market
it's super
exciting it's super fast-paced but i
think at the at the core
of what you know what we're doing is
ultimately
this point on accelerated transformation
right and i think that was very
much the very big kind of epiphany that
i had
um joining this right so we talk about
from a marketing perspective we talk a
lot about you know
how do we adopt a model that is very
iterative that you change you pivot you
learn
you fail fast and then you you know read
the cultural signals and then you adapt
and succeed
but what i'm really seeing here at
tyndall is that we're taking that kind
of marketing model of this
kind of iterative approach and really
pulling it across the entire business
model
right so obviously we're doing it in
tech
by bringing you know chicken that's from
basically the technologies from like the
stone age and bringing it into modern
day
but also iterating on top of that like
how do we make this thing tastier how do
we make it healthier how do we make it
you know eat an even greater chicken
experience
but in fundamentally in the business
model itself
you know we've we're actually probably
the best way to think about this is we
are
a tech company that's scaling food
right so our business why do you and why
do you think that
or why is it
why is it a tech company yeah so so we
our business model is actually very
simple we only do three things
so number one is we build global brands
um
number two is that we do research and
development really the ip
the the design of the product itself and
the last thing is that we
um have really strong business networks
but that means that unlike a traditional
food company
we don't own manufacturing lines we
don't own factories we don't own
trucks you know delivery trucks etc but
that means that we have the ability
to a scale exponentially very quickly
like a tech company does
um but also secondly that we're not
we have the opportunity to pivot to
change to change our strategy to learn
from
you know to fall fast into failures and
then therefore
adapt and and and succeed very quickly
because we're not encumbered with things
like well
what's the moq at the factory and do we
need to rebuild a whole new
whole uni unit people do people
question the fact that you call it
chicken when it's not chicken which is a
little bit different than burger
when it cuz it's not meat first like
like how do how does that play out like
how
how does like i see a lot of people in
the comments kind of referencing that
like
how does that play out no i mean i think
so
it's an interesting topic um first of
all it is chicken
right because what what is chicken if
you think about it a chicken is
right now it's a super archaic analog
technology where you put
soy and water into it give it a few
weeks
and then you know you end up killing the
processing unit
just to eat it essentially but isn't it
an actual chicken like the
actual animal it is absolutely so
tindall itself is first of all it's
plant-based chicken is really seen as a
final frontier
because it's actually a very difficult
meat to to essentially recreate
right because the taste profile the
the texture that consumers really demand
is one thing and and
i think tindal's really hit that mark it
is incredibly delicious
but the other piece is really the
versatility of this protein right
it's the one protein that almost every
country has its national dish you know
be it like grandma's chicken pot pie or
like a
fried chicken sandwich so it needs to
cook in
many different cooking applications many
different
uh kind of spices marinades etc
unlike a beef burger that might just be
you know a bit of salt and pepper and if
you're lucky a slice of cheese
but so so being able to nail all three
points on taste and texture and
versatility
is what's really you know been
what's very successful with tyndall and
that's really the
the thing that you know we're really
bringing to the market right so we're
meeting
and what about innovation on marketing
like instead of just
focusing on a project from a marketing
standpoint
are what are the exciting things that
you're most excited about from a
com standpoint either channels
or types of creative how are you
thinking about that
yeah i think firstly we've really
adopted this kind of this approach that
i mean
you talk about a lot too which is this
kind of iterative approach really kind
of questioning you know
why are we planning a campaign that's
gonna land three years from
like three months from now when the
world could be in a completely different
state the old school brand building
brand positioning
is just not fast enough for truth
true and and i mean i i'm testament to
that you know i went through that school
of marketing and i went through that i
was kind of
you know trained in that in that sense
and so i think going back to your point
about accelerated transformation what is
the biggest thing i've learned is like
you know we didn't need a global
pandemic to shake things up to make us
realize
like oh okay like we shouldn't be
planning campaigns for six months down
the road
putting all our eggs in one basket and
hoping that you know the creative is
right
actually we're thinking literally
marketing for the now like
marketing now this hour this afternoon
what are we putting out
how much is the challenge of driving
down the cost of creative
that is still contextual to the platform
like you find that to be such a big part
of the equation for that
yeah i think well actually so that's one
of the reasons that we've really
approached
actually having an integrated agency
right so like
rather than you know working with like
agencies that have a very traditional
model that are charging by the hour etc
we really have an in-house suite we have
you know videographers we have editors
we have designers et cetera and that
allows us to generate
way more content you know some of it's
fantastic someone's
some of that's really bad but at least
we're able to i mean like
like life people like gary but some of
it's bad i'm like
you mean like 98 of commercials like 99
of commercials are bad and they were
slow and expensive so what's the point
exactly so i think it's really embracing
this fact that like
you know it's okay to fail you know it's
not okay not to try
and therefore having as much as possible
out there
to really see what what is the consumer
feedback you know
but also really thinking like a human
being and not as like a marketer
and like okay these are my subjects that
i'm going to try and
you know convince like what do i find
funny
you know what do the people on my team
find funny or interesting
and let's put that kind of content out
there i love that
thank you so much thank you thank you
gene thank you it's okay to fail it's
not okay to try i like that
that works amazing okay right let's
bring us home
so our final guest is paulo hanlon
co-founder and exec producer of beyond
radar
paul's a tv and a media legend he's made
shows in australia
all across asia even as far as
afghanistan like in scripted content
entertainment news production everything
you name it
he's held leadership roles at
broadcasters and production companies
he was the managing director for
fremantle in asia he was also the
producer
of record-breaking entertainment shows
including asia's got talent
world scott talent um this will be a
fascinating chat so yeah welcome paul
thanks tim hi gary i'm just a bit
concerned about the uh
the lightning show it's real it's real i
might not make it
paulie i'm trying i organized that and i
organized
you putting up a painting of a chicken
after that last conversation
just to quantify that this is a chicken
or not a chicken like so
everything's working for me right now
the lightning the chicken painting i'm
on fire here
somewhere make about that rooster but we
won't go there
um actually it's not even the year of
the rooster in asia
um interestingly though you're born in i
was just checking you you know what what
year you were born in
i was born in 1975. you know no i mean
the chinese use
oh oh but i i was like damn it a
question i finally knew
no i would love to know what year it was
i'm going to tell you right now
we might be shocked to actually we're in
the year of the ox and
next year is the year of the tiger
you're born in 1975. oh you're the year
of the rabbit
that makes a ton of sense let me tell
you rabbits are highly intelligent
social and affectionate they're they're
also can be very bratty
and but but um it takes a very tight a
special type of person to work with a
rabbit
well i i i have many many many many very
special people and that is the absolute
truth
when you think about accelerating
transformation from such a creative lens
like you've had what has been the
biggest catalyst
look you know i think the most important
thing is when when we sort of look at
brands and talk about brands and what we
need to do
uh because a lot of the big productions
that tim just mentioned that i've
that i've done we've had to align
ourselves very closely with brands to
obviously
make it uh make it financial sense and i
think the most important thing is that
brands need to sort of identify
and uh we need to um work with them to
identify and entertain
audiences and i think that's the way we
should be looking through uh that's the
lens we should always be looking through
because at the end of the day
um putting aside some of the platforms
you know we need to talk to people
we need to talk to different
demographics and in different ways and i
think we also need to think about
how it can be much more creative in
doing so
because without that without that lens
um
you know most content that we make
especially across asia
won't resonate when did you first
realize
you wanted to storytell just i'm now
just kind of going off script because
i'm
enjoying the energy like when did it
when did you realize there was a
creative bug
inside of you you know i can't tell you
exactly when but it was at school
and so it started with music it started
with art then it started with coming up
with
innovative ideas and then making short
films and
it sort of progressed and then straight
out of school getting into
into media at a time when you couldn't
really go to university that's how old i
am
to learn to be a journalist effectively
you had to sort of like be creative in
the ways that you worked
so um but i think what really catapulted
it for me was when i left australia 20
odd years ago and moved to asia
when you could actually see from small
markets right up to the biggest in india
and in
indonesia and china that you can go
local you can go deep but at the
at the end of the day you it's all about
entertainment
right and i think that's the thing you
know there are the world's biggest shows
the brand's got talent x factor idol all
of those
guys you know and make a lot of money
and simon cowell is
is a very very very clever and creative
businessman however
i think the next big opportunity and
when when we talk about sort of
creativity is looking at how
we can take something from east to the
west so instead of looking at
ideas and ip which is res which has come
out of western countries and
sold around asia specifically
what can we do in in this part of the
world to actually then turn it around
and say okay
there's some incredible ideas in asia
there's also some markets which may be
small but are full of fantastic
creatives
who can then come up with ideas that
work for brands that talk to the right
people audiences in a way which makes
sense
and then look at how we can transfer
that around the region and beyond
i couldn't agree with you i mean to me
the biggest reason i have a global
organization
is the arbitrage of the context of them
being able to take that
and deploy a contextual to the other
platforms
yeah yeah 100 and i think now the
transmedia storytelling model is
is the most incredible way that we can
actually continually engage
24 7 with with audiences whether they
want
a linear part of you know because
because i think the thing you learn
when you get some of the gray hairs that
you and i have is some things are
just incredibly universally human and
other things
are incredibly not but you know a lot of
times people fight me on this and i say
did you ever think k-pop like have you
watched
k-pop bands perform in alabama and like
watch the girls go crazy you could have
never sold me on that 20 years ago
it's very clear where we are in the
world and it's a beautiful thing i think
it becomes more
team human globally and has nuances
of optimism over the next 500 years
absolutely does and i think that's the
thing that
it transcends nationality it transcends
language
it's about entertainment and engagement
and i also think you know go on are the
days where you need to sit for an hour
or an hour and a half
to watch content you know let's look
look at tik tok
let's look at five second episodes or
whatever well you know what's funny
about that i'm sorry interject
i couldn't agree with you more comma i
also believe in the reverse
like maybe the most wonderful experience
for me
from content last two years was
all eight straight hours of queen's
gambit
incredible to me i've i've believe in
this i think
there's too much fascination on length i
think that
i will stop watching a shitty six second
vine
two seconds in and i will sit through
eight hours
binging on ott and everything in between
they both work i think what people
people have definitely recognized
that we now consume more short form what
i don't think people have completely
wrapped their head around yet
is we are consuming long-form at levels
we've never thought before as a kid
intuitively creatively as a storyteller
i always wondered why four-hour movies
didn't exist because there was many
after two and a half that i was like
they should have made that three and a
half because i could see they truncated
the story and they [ __ ] it up
because they decided we won't sit here
i'll sit for [ __ ] 10 hours in the
theater watching
a new star wars and i think ott
binging has proven that and i think that
actually creates an incredible level
of innovation and storytelling because
there's a lot of humans that are willing
to go
much longer than we've historically
thought
and i think that's the great thing about
platforms now that you don't have to sit
to your 46 minutes which is a commercial
hour on telecom
free to air tv it can go for as long as
it as the story
holds right if it's entertaining and
it's a strong story
you let it run but i think also and you
just touched on that
based on the fact that you and i have a
few gray hairs you more than i because
mine's died
is the fact that i think we need to
empower young people
um more and give them the tools that
they need to actually tell the stories
that they want to tell
um and that was one of the most
incredible things that i did in my
career which is was working in
afghanistan and empowering young girls
to give a platform to be able to tell
the stories of young women who
didn't really have a way up until that
point in time to to be able to be heard
and i think
you know it doesn't take and you touched
on it earlier as well
we're not talking huge budgets on any of
these things okay the queen's gambit
bit different but
it's about an interesting story and and
how you tell it not about what the
budget is
it's insane what this does totally you
know i'm not a i'm not a
camera lens like that's not my education
but i
spend my time with many people that are
when some people explain to me the power
of this camera compared to even 15 years
ago
highest quality the innovation is there
and now
it you know what's incredible is truth
is such a foundation of a great story
isn't it
definitely it is
uh look at how we can tell those stories
in ways which are going to
engage people which is what brands need
i couldn't agree more
paul final thoughts when you think about
transformation casting
a dictator up top who she or he
pushes it uh pain in the
industry which leads to it
final thoughts on what actually leads to
actually accelerated transformation
i think what actually leads to it is is
making sure
that we are listening to what people
want and
and doing that in a way which is
collaborative
creative and commercial and i think you
need to harness all of those
elements together to push things forward
and again
earlier i agreed with everything you
said when you talked about you do a
[ __ ]
you know two-hour meeting which could
have been a 20-minute meeting with 100
people in the room instead of ten
and things just get dragged down ego
insecurity
and objects politicking peacocking
oh you do need you obviously do need to
get people on board and engage
but that's different so anyway i
appreciate your time i'm wrapping you up
thank you thank you for wrapping me up i
wish you a wonderful day
and thank you for everybody who's been
on the show tim take us home
paul gary amazing thank you so much
everyone what a wonderful bunch of smart
people
so some powerful lessons in there a
uniting theme kind of trying new things
that's what leads to change um awesome
look thank you so much
thanks gary thanks to all of our
speakers um and thanks to everybody for
joining us
uh next up um in the marketing for now
series july 22nd
um 12 to 1 p.m est so maybe a little
struggle for the asian-based audiences
here but
um but perfect for everyone else how do
you get close to customers hashtag
marketing for the now
um real quick i'm trying to interrupt
you everyone's going bananas for your
guitar collection can you give us a
little
can you tilt your camera can you give us
a little love like people are freaking
what you need i need a little action
like educate me like
why is everyone so excited like what's
going on here it's a great question you
can see my messy floor
this is this is my wife's worst
nightmare i've now got to the point
where i can't
i can't buy more but i can just buy more
expensive versions of the one i have and
just pretend they were the ones i always
had
but yeah this is my collection this is
my son's my son's two
i was born in this one as a
as an 18th birthday prayer i'm just
gonna look after it for 18 years
um just uh wait isn't he two
tim a little worried about how you're
gonna run the p l if if you're eight and
two and sixteen at eighteen
fine i mean that's gonna be like we're a
little out but it's just it's just a two
yeah brother thank you so much thanks
for having me on uh really excited about
your leadership
in apac congrats again on the promotion
uh
big shoes to feel avery's a beast but i
i have a lot of belief in you and thank
you so much for
uh architecting and orchestrating
this episode it's been amazing thanks
for hosting as always
um been able to say pleasure so yeah
cheers everyone see ya see